good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
liz tross
or rishi sunak will be our next prime
minister the final two now contenders in
the tory leadership election facing a
summer of campaigning as they set out
their stall for conservative party
members including in a head-to-head tv
debate right here on sky news while the
former chancellor has been the
front-runner throughout the contest so
far it's the foreign secretary liz tross
who's now the bookie's favorite this
morning the gloves are off she's
attacked where she sunax record on
taxation while he's claimed he's the
only one who could beat labour we'll
hear shortly from the tory pier lord
haywood and also rishi sunak's supporter
theresa villas and we'll also find out
what labour make of it all when the
shadow justice secretary steve reed
joins us here on the programme it's
thursday the 21st of july and then there
were two liz trust and rishi soon that
go head to head in the race for number
10.
what i believe is that lowering taxes
opening up opportunities is going to
help us deliver the economic growth that
britain needs
we've got to beat star we've got to beat
labour we've got to do something we've
never done before and that's win a fifth
general election we can do it i'm the
person to do it for us and that's the
message we've got to get out to our
members
i'm in wennington where fire crews are
still trying to assess the damage from
tuesday's fire and determine what caused
it
and while fires are causing havoc across
europe in parts of spain whole villages
are at risk from multiple fires breaking
out in surrounding forests
the lionesses go roaring on an extra
time goal in front of a packed stadium
in brighton means it's a step closer to
coming home
amazing just amazing i want to play for
england when i'm older same
all coventry
[Music]
look who's on the red carpet brad pitt
comes to london but this time he's not
wearing a skirt
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning the story behind the harry
and megan departure as working royals
will speak to the author tom bowz about
his new book revenge
and that's when i had a crazy idea
i was going undercover as a big game
hunting photographer i started to read a
new identity
exposing the brutal tooth about trophy
hunters we'll talk to film director
rogue rubin who raced her own life to
tell the story of the people who want to
shoot africa's lions
[Music]
good morning everybody liz trust rishi
sunak are preparing to battle it out in
the final stage of the tory leadership
election as they set out their pitches
to tory members writing in the daily
mail this morning liz tross was scathing
of the government's tax policies
overseen by her rival and promised to
push through immediate tax cuts if she
wins while rishi sunax insisting he's
the one who can beat labour over the
next six weeks they'll be campaigning
hard as they vie for party members votes
including in a head-to-head debate in a
couple of weeks right here on sky news
so what do we know about it let's bring
in straight off the bat tomorrow hi
morning morning good morning
first of all well first of all we've got
our head-to-head debate next thursday
the 4th of august on sky news and we
will have a live studio audience putting
the questions to the two people who want
to enter number 10 and they will replace
boris johnson one of them on the 5th of
september
before that of course so the
parliamentary stages have ended and now
they will go out and about around the
country and something like 160 000
conservative members will be making
their decision on who the next prime
minister is okay let me run through what
the timing is and then we'll come back
to that over the next six weeks um
hostings will take place across the
country it's a chance for the two
candidates to try to convince
conservative party members that they're
the right person for the job the first
official party hostings will take place
in leeds that's next thursday 11 other
events will follow across all four
nations of the uk then fortnight today
fourth of august sky news will be
holding a live tv debate between mr
tsunak and ms truss the next day members
will receive postal ballots and have
until 5 pm on the 2nd of september to
submit them the result will then be
announced on the 5th of september with
the winner expected to replace boris
johnson at number 10 the following day
um so it's hugely important fortnight
today the following day is when the
party members grassroot members get
their ballot papers or when they can
start submitting them
really important so the answers will be
ringing in their ears about all the
different subjects they're asked about
so far we've had some big clashes on the
economy that seems to be the main
dividing line between sunek and trust
she wants to cut taxes from day one he
says no we have to get inflation under
control first but their views on the nhs
crime immigration the war in ukraine all
these other issues may be asked by our
studio audience and that will send
signals to conservative party members
about who they may want to be the next
prime minister they will have to make up
their minds during that period yeah
we've been hearing both from uh rishi
sunay and also liz trust and we'll be
hearing what they had to say in just a
second
it's gonna start getting nasty
it has been quite a nasty contest
already lots of personal attacks which
is thought to be the reason that they
pulled out of another debate that we'd
organized earlier and we can already see
labour are already using the lines from
those tv debates as attacks kierstarma
at prime minister's questions yesterday
saying how do the conservatives feel
their time in government is going take
them at their word with liz trust saying
the tax burden has been at its highest
for 70 years and writing in the daily
mail which the newspaper supporting her
today she continues that attack on rishi
sunak saying we can't have business as
usual managerialism on the economy we
need to be radical whereas rishi sunak
although he took the gloves off in the
debate attacking liz trust as a former
remainer and a former liberal democrat
he says in his article in the telegraph
today that he respects her as a friend
and colleague but certainly on that
issue of brexit he may well be
pushing the members to understand that
he was the one who voted for it
originally so yes it could get very
nasty between their supporters but who
is going to take the crown it was four
o'clock yesterday afternoon when we
found out that penny morden was out of
the contest she'd run a good race but
her time as uh trying to be the next
prime minister of this country is over
this is what the other two said
i am going to be working very hard over
the next six weeks to put my case to
conservative party members what i
believe is that lowering taxes opening
up opportunities is going to help us
deliver the economic growth that britain
needs
i'm really proud of the campaign that
we've run right we have been honest we
have been positive about everyone about
what we're doing and now we've got a job
to do to take that message to the
membership right and yes look do we
start behind we do but we've already
moved the numbers a huge amount in the
space of a week right but the most
important thing for everyone to realize
is that we need to win the next election
right and now we've got to focus our
minds enough talking amongst ourselves
we've got to beat star we've got to beat
labour we've got to do something we've
never done before and that's win a fifth
general election we can do it i'm the
person to do it for us and that's the
message we've got to get out to our
members
well joining us now conservative peer
and pollster lord hayward good morning
thank you for joining us on the program
um
labor want liz trusts to win why is that
from the conversations i've had with
labour peers and one or two labour mps
the frank conversations they're not
trying to kind of
maneuver a double bluff or something
they see rishi's weaknesses as his tax
position and his wealth
but he is a success story
and they believe that will probably go
down well in places like leicester and
bradford um
whereas liz truss has not subjected
herself to
a full cross-examination
by any of the major programs and didn't
perform well
in the debates
and therefore they feel that in at the
dispatch box
that she will be easier as a target
and easier to to take down
do you have to be a good debater to be a
good prime minister
you need that skill because we have this
very brutal process in our parliament of
uh prime minister's question time every
wednesday
and although
the vast majority of the population
doesn't watch it it's that that
percolates through the party members
through the associations and therefore
people will be judging it in terms of
who's going to win my marginal seat
how surprised were you by the result
yesterday not really um i'm more
surprised by the earlier rounds where
the ebbs and flows are voting whether
there was a bit of conspiracy and
maneuvering i'm not really sure because
there was
of course there was you know i'm not you
know i'm fairly cynical about
politicians yeah so yeah they're not
there's nothing wrong with that
absolutely perfectly entitled to do and
it happens in other organizations and
businesses as well uh but the actual
outcome once we got to the final round
uh a marginal liz trust victory over
penny morton uh was likely
i think just the way the voters the
people who were
then available in terms of uh casting
their votes who previously voted for
other candidates were likely just
slightly uh more heavily to go for liz
trust so penny morgan um i mean it was
always the bookie's favorite they were
they were you don't you really see a
poor bucky do you so what happened there
i think the answer is
and it's one of the reasons one has to
be cautious about looking at any opinion
poll of members is because actually the
support has ebbed and flowed quite
markedly in the last two or three weeks
between one candidate and another and of
course one of the key things that both
candidates will now be looking to
is to get the support of penny mordant
and her supporters out in the country
because support from penny could well be
key when it comes to votes in
constituencies interesting i was at the
30 last uh yesterday actually just to
kill a mockingbird if you haven't seen
it you should go it's amazing happily um
and uh there was a chap during the
intervals saying is penny morgan's going
to win because i've got 20 quid on her
at 25 to 1. um so she's still very much
you know there or there about on
people's minds very much isn't she will
she be the king maker
she could influence the result there's
absolutely no question that and by the
way my brother's also had money on penny
morton
he's done it really as well then yeah
but no
she could well have a major influence
and mps themselves will influence their
constituency associations because
members who don't know liz trust or
issue that well will turn to their mp
where they have a conservative mp and
say who do you support why did you
support them will it benefit me as a
council candidate at the next local
elections these are the sorts of
questions and conversations that will be
taking place over the next few weeks who
do you think she'll fall in behind i
don't know i spoke to her briefly
yesterday but that was she before she
was fine but that was before the result
so i haven't spoken to her since
um but
she may keep her own council she may go
public uh kemi begnock and michael gove
two other very influential people have
not said anything at this stage
they are also the sorts of people who
will influence conservative members how
nasty is this going to get
it's not nice um you look at primaries
in the united states you look at what
happens in france in terms of leadership
contests uh it's it's not nice
but what actually happens in the long
run is that particularly because we're
likely to have one and a half to two
euros till the next general election
um
they kiss and make up might be a slight
exaggeration but there's no question
that
issues
will become policy issues will become
far more important than what was said in
in mid mid 2022.
talk to me about how the next six weeks
play out because um in the movie
industry they call it hitches so there
are certain hitches as you go along what
are we watching out for well
clearly the two debates for the reason
that i identified at the start uh
liz trust didn't do well in either of
the two debates particularly paulie in
the first one so for her
those two appearances
and any individual cross-examinations
at length that she
makes on any uh programme will be key
for her and
they're important for rishi as well one
shouldn't underestimate that and
you and pollsters and everybody always
saying this is how they performed
that's the key thing but also
there will be the meetings of party
members
which people are being notified of and
again particularly the early ones if i
was managing either of campaigns and i'm
sure they're taking that view they've
got to get everything front loaded
because
many people having received their ballot
will actually just return it asap
so you need to get the the blow the
comments in very early so you don't
stick it on the fridge and sort of wait
for six weeks to see how it's going to
pass some people might do and then
forget about it rather than
exactly some people forget their lottery
tickets so uh uh but yes so i think the
majority will be returned fairly quickly
and they're open the ballots open from
the fifth of august the day after our
debate from the fifth of august
and the result will be declared on the
fifth of september okay um what about
hustings how does she do in hustings
list
well
we'll find out how well she did but say
there is a sense that the first of
particularly the first of the two
debates she didn't do well in and the
hustings are going to be fairly similar
um in terms of process
for party members and therefore
um those will matter because even people
who are not able to to get in or
watch them virtually
they will have friends who go or watch
and they
will communicate with each other and the
big issues you think are inflation cost
of living and and it's we still hear
about brexit and i know that rishi sunak
was having a pop up this trust about her
being a former remainer does it matter
anymore are we all brexiteers now i
think and i've made this observation i
think on this program previously that
the level of factionalism re-brexit has
diminished from previous leadership
elections
you can say obviously the obvious ones
are things like the economy and taxation
but i think it's likely that there will
be surprise issues
you covered
as did everybody the fires yesterday
funding of the fire service funding of
the health service if there is a
particular crisis in some form or
another will suddenly become center
stage
and therefore the next few weeks are
going to be highly unpredictable because
it will be responsive to what are the
major news stories of that particular
week and do you think green levees and
climate change has its place i spoke to
one mp who said because there was
pressure why don't we just vote every
day two or three times a day till we get
down to two candidates and one mp said i
don't know what the candidates views are
on environment matters so there were a
number of mps who were advocating that
they should have which they did have
internal hustings to cover the issues
which are important to large sections of
the population
um what are the polls telling you
internal polls telling you as far as
these two candidates are concerned at
the moment there's no question liz truss
is in the lead um you have
a respected and long-term pollster but
even those polls from the different
companies have fluctuated quite
dramatically as you said penny was
favorite um only a few days ago to win
um so the polls the betting fluctuating
a lot so that says there is a lot of
people out there who actually haven't
decided they haven't got foreign views
one way or the other and how interesting
is it how concerning should it be for
the conservative party for the
government that they seem to have such a
disconnect between the mps and what the
grassroots think
i'm not sure whether there is that
disconnect i think there is a
fluctuation the mps were desperate to
get rishi soon act through whereas it
seems grassroots are not at all well
we've got one poll on one day but you
there are other polls that have shown
fluctuations over the last two or three
weeks so as i said just now don't take
one poll as a clear indication of where
they've been set previous elections
leadership elections have been very much
more more clear
it's been set on a certain course and
that's where it's gone to um it went out
to the members between boris and jeremy
but we we knew that boris was going to
win that's not so clear this time and
therefore there will be
say the hitch points uh during the next
few weeks on issues that have been
unexpected
and
candidates stumble but they don't often
fall no who's going to win my lord uh
i'm waiting to see
i genuinely don't know
because of this fluctuation in the
opinion polls
uh and the messages that i'm hearing
there are let's say there's a lot of
people who don't know
uh in the membership
and there have been varying views and
then say those who are supporting penny
morton a large block of the party both
within mps and outside have they've got
to decide
and and that's why debates are so
important they are okay it's great to
see my thank you for coming in as always
thank you thank you just a reminder in
two weeks time we'll see those two
candidates go head to head here on sky
news we'll have that live televised
debate as the pair continue with their
campaigns to become the next leader of
the conservative party and the country's
next prime minister i'm going to be
hosting that debate for you on thursday
the 4th of august which is two weeks
today and that's at 8 00 pm with a
studio audience live here on sky news i
know that you're not going to want to
miss that one
looking at the papers the eye reporting
liz trusts is the new favorite to become
prime minister with the foreign
secretary ahead in polls at of i should
say of conservative party members
in the mail this trust vows to hold an
emergency budget to cut taxes and stand
up to those who have uh talking down our
country history and values
advantage trusts in the race to ppm is
the telegraph's headline as rishi sunak
writes in the paper that he respects his
opponent and recognizes the need for tax
cuts but the times leads on suggestions
from the former chancellor that the
conservatives will lose power unless he
is elected
the guardian says the tory party is
brave through a blue on blue dog fight
as the six weeks of hustings kick off
today
meanwhile the sun leads on the funeral
for bowel babe dame deborah james with
the headline love and miss you forever
lots more still to come on the programme
including conservative mp therese
williams will be here shortly she's
backing rishi sunak to become the next
prime minister but liz trust is said to
be the bookies favorite we'll get her
take on that
citizens advice is now referring almost
700 people a day to food banks but how
much pressure can they take we're gonna
be chatting to taz khan of the london
community kitchen
and then just after eight shadow justice
secretary steve reed will be joining me
here in the studio to give us his
thoughts on the tory contest
meantime the residents of wennington are
still discovering the full extent of the
destruction in the village after
wildfires swept through it on tuesday
the hottest day yet on record here in
the uk let's speak to saudia who's
standing by for us this morning hello
sardia how are they getting on
hi kay well look it's a little bit
different from yesterday that police
cordon that we saw that stretched a long
way around this area has shrunk
considerably but there is still a
presence here and as you say the
residents will slowly start to discover
what's happening fire crews are still
working within that coordination of
course this wasn't the only fire in the
area we had that
large blaze in upminster there were a
number of fires across london i think on
tuesday 102 fire trucks i'd counted had
to be deployed to various parts of
london in yorkshire as well there were
big blazes there lots of fire crews
deployed there and just in the last few
minutes we've had an update from london
fire brigade that ablaze this morning at
a sports pavilion in southall has now
come under control eight fire trucks
deployed there but here as i say
residents still not allowed to go back
to their homes in that worst affected
area inside that gordon
region but yesterday afternoon some
people who had lost power as a safety
precaution did have their electricity
returned but there is still
that smell of burnt smoke and smoke
in the air here as you drive around you
can get it despite that overnight rain
and that wind that we had the fire crews
still working to try and assess that
damage as you say and try and determine
what caused it in much cooler
temperatures today highs of 25 degrees
here
okay thank you thanks a lot freddie
well the heat wave is uh oh actually
let's just have a look at um liz trust
mcco come back to europe in just a
second she's just been leaving home i
wonder if she said anything this morning
let's find out
okay no it's the answer um
um maybe we should see that will tell us
something a bit later on i think we're
probably um seeing what he has to say
this morning as well these six weeks of
hustings begin now we'll know who our
next prime minister is by the fifth of
september uh meantime the heat is
certainly on not only here in the uk but
also across europe as i was saying let's
have a look at this one of the worst
affected countries is spain
there the wildfires are continuing to
burn including across these still
smoldering mountains in galithea to the
northwest of the country
from there our climate change and energy
correspondent hannah thomas peter
reports
it's hard going for the fire crews in
the mountains of galicia in northwestern
spain
wildfires are popping up everywhere
we find a team that's scrambling to stop
this one moving any closer to the
village just below
it just sparked helper fernandez tells
me it crossed on the wind from a
different fire and reached over here
these blazes are burning quickly through
the drought parched forest worrying for
the firefighters who live in the places
they are trying to protect
we're being moved
okay as the flames push us back
volunteer carlos prada explains one of
the central challenges of tackling fires
here
the real problem he says is there's no
place to put the firefighting machinery
that's the real problem
the terrain is utterly unforgiving some
fires can't even be reached
it's a huge effort just to move up and
down the rocky slopes
they're using diggers to push
brush and plants and dry twigs and logs
out of the way to try and create a fire
break the firefighters have let us come
up the hill to watch them finish up
they've just put out a fire just to see
how dangerous it is how hot and dry it
is and how once they put out one set of
flames another lot pops up
district fire chief lorena fernandez
knows that if communities want to remain
here things have to change
the administration
the administration has to invest she
says the forests have to be more
carefully managed and the land kept
clear around these mountains
but in the nearby province of zamora
where the blackened forests run for
miles another fire chief is
contemplating a different problem
do you think fire season is getting
worse as climate change makes the planet
hotter of course there's no doubt about
that i have been working for 22 years
and we have never been seen that
condition on the fire never it's
completely new for us
tens of thousands of acres burned
thousands of people evacuated
deaths injuries and the fires are still
burning
this nation paying a high price as our
world heats up
hannah thomas peter sky news in galicia
in spain
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and some of the
biggest uk retailers will offer new
deals to help families struggling with
soaring prices over the summer holidays
businesses including asda and amazon
have agreed to slash some costs as part
of the government's help for households
campaign
an inquiry into the handling of the
covid 19 pandemic by the government will
be launched today baroness heather
hallett will chair the inquiry which
will cover the uk's response to and the
impact of the pandemic
meanwhile the nord stream pipeline which
brings natural gas from russia into
germany has reopened this morning the
pipeline is expected to operate at
around 30 percent capacity but president
putin has warned it could be reduced
european commission president ursula van
der lion accused russia of blackmailing
the eu
and russia's threatening to expand its
military operation in ukraine even
further if the west continues to send
long-range weapons the foreign minister
sergey lavrov said russia's ambition now
stretched beyond ukraine's eastern
territories holiday plans for thousands
of people may be in jeopardy because
more than half a million passports were
still waiting to be processed at the end
of june the passport office has warned
that the delays could continue over the
summer and may not improve before the
end of the year
and the union united suspended the
strike at london's heathrow airport
which was due to begin today it follows
an improved pay offer from the company
here's a question for you on a thursday
morning what'd you do
if you discover a bear on your balcony i
know happens a lot let's take a look
here we go get out from there right now
go go go go you get down from my porch
right now go go what do you think you're
doing on my porch
you get down
go and don't come back either former
teacher debbie tomlinson from north
carolina was not having any of it when a
bear climbed onto the porch of her
holiday home and tried to steal her bird
feeders she used what she calls her
teacher voice to encourage the naughty
creature to leave her property i use my
teacher voice sometimes too quick look i
know it's a surprise looking at the
weather
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
cooler more unsettled mainly dry today
mostly fine and mild now but the
southeast has a few showers while
central england is cloudy
with a little patchy light rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
also coming up on the program for you
this morning a new action thriller
featuring hollywood legend brad pitt
premiered in london yesterday bullet
train has a star-studded cast also
featuring the likes of sandra bullock
and rapper bad bunny
i've never heard of him and the man
himself was on the red carpet too as was
katie
[Music]
off the back of a sweltering heat wave
how about a master class of cool
perennial heartthrob brad pitt wasn't
wearing a skirt for the london premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
brad pitt's producing work means he
appears on screen a little less these
days but he's still willing to flash his
leading man credentials should the right
project take his fancy
i mean i feel like i should see namaste
yes yes he's he's working on his
mindfulness
not going so well yeah not for an
assassin i mean it's a real conflict of
interest isn't it no no interesting
combination i think wasn't the human
that drew you to this that fight things
of themselves absolutely i mean i read
this like in that in the middle of
lockdown before we even had a vaccine
and it just made me laugh and i thought
yeah this is what i want to see well
that's crazy ladybug ladybug
based on kataro isaka's best-selling
book pitt plays an unlucky assassin
while the punches look real he was in
safe hands with director david leach a
former hollywood stunt man himself who
back in the day doubled for pitt and six
of his biggest films including fight
club and mr and mrs smith
he is the same um
humble spirit and a generous
collaborator and incredible artist that
he's always been
but it's good to see him with all these
years under his belt delivering at the
highest level and we're just so grateful
we got that brad
now that's far off turning 60 although
brad pitt reportedly earns almost 20
million dollars of film he is now a
prolific producer behind the scenes and
in one recent magazine interview he said
includes his film career that's winding
down
i'm gonna hurt people
but with back-to-back fight scenes in
this there's no sign of him slowing down
no we're all game the stunt guys are
always they're overly protective of us
you know what i mean
as those who've worked with him will
attest there is a rare timelessness to
brad pitt's hollywood movie star while
he might be happy away from all that
attention hopefully he's a little way
off retirement katie spencer sky news
do you remember the first movie that he
was ever in
i'll tell you later on looking at some
of the best pictures making the
morning's papers here we go after the
heat comes the storm the daily mail has
this shot a forks of lightning near the
village of elmley in kent the met office
is warning of sudden thunderstorms and
the risk of flash flooding as rain is
expected to replace the scorching heat
in some parts of england
in the telegraph at glasgow science
center celebrates its 21st anniversary
its executive chef and that's stephen
breslin performs the fire hands which
uses a combination of liquid soap gas
and water don't try that at home folks
and hold on i'm just putting it in
bark
the time shows us entries in the animal
friends comedy pets photo contest
including a smoking alpaca and a horse
that looks like it's had one too many
uh cabernets
that was a really bad joke i did not
write that one jack wrote that one i'm
very sorry but this one is very funny
just putting it into bark top stories
for you this morning on the programme
the conservative leadership contest has
reached the last two candidates either
rishi sunak or liz tross will be the
next prime minister
fire crews in wennington are continuing
to assess the damage after the
devastating fire there earlier this week
and england's women through to the
semi-finals of the euros after an extra
time girl secured them a 2-1 win against
spain
trader videos is here with us you want
to say something about the women's
lionesses first they were amazing
i didn't see the game but they've
obviously been doing fantastically well
i i wish them well for the next day yeah
maybe they could be bringing it home
let's see i think the final is at
wembley let's hope they get that far and
lift the trophy it's great to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
supporting wishy sunak i am yes okay um
what happened yesterday because it looks
as though penny mordant was a shoe-in to
go through and she didn't
i think there's there's a lot of support
for rishi in the parliamentary party and
that was recognized in his coming top of
the ballot i think it'll be um you know
there'll be a tough contest ahead both
rishi and liz are strong candidates but
i believe that he is the our best chance
of winning in the general election and
he's got a plan to get a grip on
inflation grow the economy and reduce
our taxes was there any skullduggery
with votes being handed around
well certainly not that i was aware of
but um
this is a victoriously sophisticated
electorate so some of my colleagues no
doubt did
probably different mps voted tactically
but um
the rishi campaign was strongly
encouraging only all its supporters to
vote for rishi we weren't engaging in
these tactical voting games because
penny morton of course would have been
some say a more formidable
challenger than liz trust do you agree
both penny annelise have great great
qualities i mean we had some fantastic
candidates in the mp rounds
now it's down to the membership to pick
the person who's going to win us a
general election
um are you going to are you going to
tell your candidates to stop tearing
lumps out of each other
i absolutely want a positive contest um
and some of the testing's comments were
you know it's always difficult when
you've got um
people within the same party competing
against one another but um i know rishi
wants to make a positive case about what
he's going to do to get us through
what are going to be very difficult
economic times do you think he regrets
the comment that he made on the itv
debate about which she regrets more
being a remainer or being a libdem
i mean that that wasn't the greatest
moment in his campaign i i
you know i i probably regret that i'm
i'm not sure that was the right thing to
do but
the important thing is
who is is going to be the person to get
us through
this inflation crisis and i think
ritchie has demonstrated he's got the
track record and he's got the plan
to do that but he wants to
certainly not decrease taxes for now um
how will that go down with the party
faithful
i hope they'll recognize that actually
if both the two candidates want to
reduce taxes
but
rishi is the one who recognises that
because of the inflation crisis that we
face because of covert debt
we need a degree of caution he's
determined to get our taxes down but
only once inflation is beaten first but
if somebody's offering jam today it's
very difficult especially in a cost of
living crisis to think oh actually i
won't vote for that
our members i think recognize that
thatcherism is about sound money as well
as low taxes mrs thatcher
her prime focus when she first arrived
as prime minister was fixing the public
finances and getting inflation under
control and grappling with economic
problems before she started cutting
taxes in a big way
why is there such a disconnect between
mps
um conservative mps and conservative
grassroots voters because it looks as
though you know he's obviously very
popular your candidate with mps he won
the ballot easily but when it comes to
tory grassroots voters who will decide
who is the next prime minister he's not
quite as popular why is that
well to be honest we don't know what the
membership think polling conservative
party members is a notoriously difficult
thing you know politicians always say
this and it's a bit like and somebody
said to me a pollster said to me
yesterday the day before it's a bit like
um actors saying they never read reviews
of course you take notice of the polls
i think i very much hope members will be
impressed by
rishi's three-point plan
to get us through these difficult
economic times we need someone who's
demonstrated that he can
he can have a grip on the government
that he can deliver
you know the policies we need to win us
a general election i believe that he
will get our taxes down but he won't he
wants to do it in a responsible way yeah
the problem is um him being a judas
according to some with the prime
minister is not going to serve him well
prime minister having a poverty
yesterday from the dispatch box well i i
don't believe in that kind of
characterization at all i think that's
that's really unfair
um i it's
it's obviously been very damaging to the
conservative party as a whole the
circumstances that led to a resignation
of a prime minister these these events
are deeply traumatic but now we need a
fresh start we need to elect a new
legion and then
unite behind that new leader do you
think that when the prime minister
yesterday was um saying what he was
saying about don't always um
take the advice of the treasury um he
was particularly indirectly referring to
your guy
you'll have to ask boris and his team
that but yeah
it is important for any minister in a
department to to challenge the orthodoxy
of their civil servants i'm sure rishi
was was able to do that in his time and
i'm sure if he does become our prime
minister
he will be taking forward those ideas in
the manifesto on which we're all elected
and um he'd be prepared to challenge the
civil servants to make sure that um they
deliver on those promises that we made
to the electorate at the general
election what did you make of labour not
standing up for the prime minister
yesterday
i'm sorry i didn't quite catch that
labour not standing up for the prime
minister to applaud him uh on his last
prime minister's questions yesterday
what did you think of that
i i think it would have been courteous
for for everyone to have taken part in
that applause because as um an outgoing
prime minister that's a huge occasion
and i believe that uh
boris has delivered a huge amount for
this country not least getting brexit
done and also
guiding us through
the worst health emergency for 100 years
with one of the most successful vaccine
programs
in the world so i think that deserved
recognition and applause theresa may
didn't
i did well
that's a matter for her i mean if if you
have questions about that that's
there to be directed at her churlish
well i i as i say i think um an outgoing
prime minister deserves applause
particularly one who leaves the country
with important benefits as a result of
his premiership
what are you most anxious about over the
next six weeks
where should i start where should i
start
um
i think anything can happen in this
membership vote but i know that
rishi and his team are going to be
working incredibly hard
to
convince the members on this and he'll
be bringing forward
fresh ideas on how we fix the economy in
particular how we get business investing
how we improve our skills training so we
invest in
making us a more productive economy
because that's ultimately the thing
that's going to raise living standards
and getting get us through this
inflation crisis and what are you most
looking forward to apart from obviously
hoping that your candidate wins on the
5th of september is it the debate of
fortnight today
i think i'm quite looking forward to
this being parliament's um last day
sitting before the summer recess so that
um
there's a few of us who who get a little
something of a break but
i think
we'll see some some great debates in the
hustings i hope they're well attended by
the membership
and um i believe that the membership
will recognize that in difficult times
we need someone with proven experience
and an economic plan to get us through
difficult times great to see thanks for
joining us on the program very much
gracie enjoy your break as well thank
you thanks very much
uh well at the start of the programme
today we were chatting um to lord
haywood and he was telling us what he
thinks will happen between uh rishi
sunak um what potentially what will
happen between uh rishi sunak and liz
trust um he talked about all things
leadership contest he said the
head-to-head debates will be
particularly telling
liz trust didn't do well in either of
the two debates particularly paulie in
the first one so for her
those two appearances
and any individual cross-examinations
at length that she
makes on any uh programme will be key
for her
and
they're important for rishi as well one
shouldn't underestimate that and
you and pollsters and everybody always
saying this is how they performed
that's the key thing
oh well let's bring in ed dave we should
we he is the leader of the liberal
democrats it's great to see thanks for
joining us on the programme as always
did you applaud the prime minister
yesterday
no i didn't and the reason is that um i
called his resignation uh some months
ago
and i think he's been a very poor prime
minister
breaking the law but most importantly
failing to help millions of families and
pensioners so it would have been
hypocritical to
applaud and i found it a little bit
weird if i'm honest with you that all
these conservative mps who'd just knifed
boris johnson in the back we're now
applauding him and it seemed it seemed
quite surreal to me um uh but we weren't
going to be hypocritical i left that to
the conservatives
um what did you make of the fact that um
theresa may didn't stand up or she did
eventually but she certainly didn't
applaud was that a bit chillish
i think she was being true to what she
thought i don't think she's ever rated
boris johnson as a good prime minister
um and
in that in that regard i agree with her
i think boris johnson has been very bad
for the country
and i think he's divided the country i
think he
has got a dreadful record on so many
things particularly economy
um and with inflation going through the
roof and the cost of living crisis
like nothing we've seen for generations
i think he bears a heavy responsibility
for the the pain that many families are
feeling now
um
and then there were two head-to-head uh
debates uh coming up four hours as a
fortnight today um finally got that over
the line what do you want to hear from
those debates
well i'd like to hear a real plan a plan
for our economy but in particular
a plan for the millions of
families and pensioners who are facing a
financial catastrophe
this autumn already we know and you and
i have discussed this before okay
haven't we um so many people are
struggling out there with food bills
filling their
cars worried about their heating bills
this winter and we know it's going to
get worse we saw inflation going up
again this month
and we know that um the energy price cap
is going to go up hundreds of pounds
again
in the autumn and it's the big elephant
in the room and i've been shocked up
till now to be honest in the tory
leadership candidate debates that it's
like the elephant in the room this is a
huge iceberg coming to hit people this
catastrophe
just uh over horizon and none of them
seem to be addressing that problem they
seem to be talking about you know how to
help better off people wealthy people uh
tory party members they're not talking
about how to help the tens of millions
of families and pensioners who are
desperately worried at the moment
why would somebody want to be a prime
minister at the moment to try to
navigate us through this catastrophe
well if you're a patriot and you want to
help our country in an hour of crisis
then you should stand up
and as a liberal democrat i believe that
uh we have policies that could help the
country at the moment and i mean i've
been advocating them across the country
we've won three by-elections in the last
year against the conservatives in their
heartlands because we've been arguing
for real help for families and
pensioners faced with this cost-living
emergency we'd talk for example about a
cut-in vat
that would both reduce inflation it
would help businesses on the high street
but it in particular it would deliver a
600 pound tax cut to families and
pensioners and you know that's the sort
of practical policy
that is right for the moment that
liberal democrats have been putting
forward and we've been putting it full
responsibility because i was the first
politician to talk about a windfall tax
to get the money from the oil and gas
companies who are making so much money
at the moment and give it back to people
who are struggling and so um i want to
hear
positive policies like little democrats
have been putting forward and you know
you ask about
who do you want to run the country well
i think people do if they want to help
people and if they're a patriot okay um
it's great to see you um as always come
in and see us um soon thank you very
much indeed thanks
thank you
a high court challenge against the
government's plan to deport some asylum
seekers to rwanda has been delayed until
september several groups have brought
challenges against the plan to provide
one-way tickets to the east african
country so we're still waiting to find
out what is going to happen as far as
that is concerned originally it was
supposed to happen in the summer then it
was supposed to happen around about
september time now it looks as though it
will not be
until november we will analyze that for
you in more detail in just a moment or
two before that though let me tell you
about england's lionesses they're
through to the semi-finals of the euros
after beating spain in extra time in a
thrilling match in brighton uh standing
by for us is tom um he
there is in brighton for us this morning
wow what was it like in the stadium
it was breathless it was raucous and it
was one of the most memorable nights for
english football as the lionesses came
from behind last night to snatch victory
in the last throws of the match and it
was their coach serena wiegmann back
from about of covid back on the
touchline and she took a huge gamble
spain had gone one nil up there was
the closing stages of the game and she
made a big substitution she took off
ellen white she took off um
beth mead and two of the leading scorers
uh for england in this tournament and of
all time and she switched them in with
alessia rousseau and ella tune it was
those two who combined to put england
level and take it into extra time and
that is just the point of course when
you need a hero to step forward and step
forward georgia stanway she said before
the tournament she just wants to put
smiles on people's faces it was an
incredible strike to win it it sent them
home delirious at the amex stadium last
night and we were speaking to some of
the fans as they streamed out of the
stadium they just couldn't quite believe
what they'd just seen a real fighting
performance from the lionesses they have
togetherness in this squad they have
belief in this squad and it will be
sweden or belgium next in sheffield next
tuesday and a semi-final appointment the
final is at wembley and the lionesses
really you would expect them after this
this building of performances through
this tournament now to perhaps get to
that final and maybe who knows even win
it okay okay thank you joining us uh now
is human rights barrister adam wagner
he's going to talk to us about what is
going on with these one-way tickets to
rwanda or otherwise hi adam um a couple
of technical thank you please you're
with us now good morning good morning
what's happening
um so the high court has just ruled that
there's going to be a hearing a full
hearing for five days in october to
decide whether this policy is lawful or
not um and in the meantime we've seen um
or we've heard about a number of
internal um home office documents which
suggest um it might be a problematic
policy even more so than we thought
okay so
originally
we saw
much trumpeted a visit to rwanda from
our home secretary we've paid them a
shed load of money um but it was the
european convention on human rights that
got in the way was it
um
only partially because it was actually
our courts that um blocked a number of
the um
deportations um as well as the european
court of human rights but yeah i mean
we do
sign up to human rights and asylum law
and we've got to keep keep to them and i
think this policy well quite obviously
the home office has always been advised
that this policy
gives rise to very serious risks um that
the courts will will strike it down um
which which you'd expect for sending
vulnerable asylum seekers to a country
with a poor asylum system
what are the different different
possible outcomes um next time this goes
to court
well i the court might give it a clean
bill of health and say um it's a lawful
policy in which case the government will
be able to start flights again i mean
technically you could probably start
flights um now but i doubt it will
especially given the what's going on in
the politics
but um even then each flight would
become a sort of
drama of uh last minute applications
because the government the policy itself
is so vulnerable it's a legal challenge
because you're sending people before
their asylum claims have been fully
assessed into what could be for them a
dangerous environment so you're going to
have every single time there's a flight
you'll have last minute legal challenges
and not because the lawyers are trying
to get one over on the government
because it's a last-minute policy that
is in the policy operates at the last
minute so you have to get into court so
a clean bill of health at this stage
would not
um make the policy work and i think the
policy is still pretty risky um but but
the high court could also strike down
the policy or essentially say the
policies are lawful and the government
would have to um think again so that and
that would be the
nuclear result for the government
and when will we know
um well i mean it's being heard in
october the call could take months after
that to decide the case although i
imagine it will feel under some pressure
to get it out as quickly as possible
okay but just to clarify the government
could start sending planes to rwanda
again from today but if they did try to
do that it would be held on the runway
while there were challenges in in the
courts which is probably why they did it
i i just don't think it's happened i
think if there wasn't a toy leadership
challenge it it
could in theory happen but i don't think
the government's got the bandwidth to
deal with that kind of issue at the
moment i really doubt i just i think
technically it could because you could
send a whole because the individuals who
were on that flight were prevented from
being sent by the courts but you could
in theory send different individuals but
then you have a raft of all the same
problems because i mean one of the
interesting things that came out of this
court challenge so far is that the home
office has been advised by the foreign
office um over and over again and the
fight i think the foreign office itself
has been advised by civil servants that
there's a real risk that the romans
asylum policy isn't up to scratch there
are significant human rights concerns it
got a amber or red warning when they
were looking at potential countries last
year
um so i i think that
the chances of this policy succeeding
i've never thought the flight would ever
take off because it's such a it's a
crazy policy such a crazy way of dealing
with asylum seekers and it's it's quite
a cruel one as well so i'm pretty
you know i still think it's unlikely
anybody will ever go to rewind from this
policy but i could be wrong
okay um we need to let you get to court
i know um adam it's good to talk to you
as always thank you very much thank you
in other news citizens advice says
staggering numbers of people are in need
of food banks it says local authorities
are overwhelmed and it's referring
almost 700 people a day to food banks
nearly double the number of a year ago
it comes as the government has today
launched its help for households
campaign which will see big businesses
offering new deals to help families well
let's speak now to those khan the
founder of the london community kitchen
friend of the programme of course hi taz
great to see you this morning what are
you seeing are more and more people
coming to use your food banks
morning k yes we're seeing unprecedented
demands
a lot of people are being referred to us
from several organizations and i just
think people like myself all across
london are struggling to cope
and what are you doing about
donations are they still coming in or
are they starting to dry up
they are starting to dry up some of our
largest contributors the big boys
who used to send pallets a week here
that has disappeared the food chain
itself is seeing a shortage nationally
and we're seeing the impact of that
so what are you doing how are you still
able to help
it's just very very difficult we're
having to go out to farms
who can't sell some of their produce go
we have to go outside of london we just
have to work extremely extremely harder
to ensure we can support the same kind
of people
yeah i i see that um tesco asda m s
morrisons they're all offering um help
with kids eating free in their cafes if
parents eat their um as well you sort of
have that model as well don't you have a
cafe there to help people
yeah so we have a cafe um
is what it is it's called the kind cafe
open to anyone people can come and have
a free meal for themselves and their
children and even pensioners are
struggling they can have a free meal but
you know it's it's not the solution this
is it's really worrying times we were we
were prepared in the pandemic we knew
what we were facing but this one it's
just firing out of control and this is
beyond what we can do as long as
um what are people who are potentially
watching in northwest london this
morning and they need your help they're
very welcome just to come to the door
100 always always okay good to see you
as as always thanks very much indie
thank you thank you